which makes sense because I do know
they have
like
classification the
just write one
page unless there's something
my roommate.
New Jersey
probably
like so I didn't want to go
I also
So I feel like
Okay, folks, I'm going to get started.
reminders again that uh your numbers for
your DCF value, your pricing, and your
recommendation. If you can put those
into that master spreadsheet by Sunday
at midnight because I need it for the
Monday class, that would help, you know,
little. So, if you get it done earlier,
great. So, don't wait till 11:59 p.m.
because I said midnight. you know, you
have 7:00 a.m. you get it done, put it
at because and again, the price you
should use should be the Friday closing
price, right? So, so with that leading,
let's let's talk a little bit about what
today's class is going to be about.
We're going to complete the discussion
of M&A as synergy and all the rest of
the stuff related to acquisitions, but
we're also going to talk about things
that you can do to change the value of
your business. Why might you be
interested in changing the value of your
business?
In which direction you want to change
it? Let's get that out of the way. You
want to increase it, right? If you want
to decrease the value, I can give you
100 easy ways to do it, right? You want
to increase the value. You're saying as
a passive investor, that might not be
something you care about, right? because
you're buying a company want to but but
if you're it's your business it's not
just you're not just interested in what
the value of your business is but you
also have a follow-up question what can
I do to make my business more
valued the second place where this can
come in useful is if you're a consultant
you know and I'm not talking about the
consultant you're using because you
don't want to take responsibility for
your decisions but the consultant you
call in and say I have a company I'm in
trouble what can I do to change the
value to increase the value of my
company. In many ways, what you're going
to see me do is now go back to my
corporate finance core because up till
now, you could just say capital
struggle, the debt policy is the debt
policy. Nothing I can do about it. The
company takes bad projects. I'm going to
price it in. Nothing I can do about it.
Now, you can do something about it. So,
to to start the discussion off, which
will start in about 30 minutes, I'm
going to ask you a couple of questions
which I think cut to the heart of what
this entire process is going to be
about.
I'm going to list out a series of
actions and I want you to tell me
whether they will affect value and if so
in which direction. By now we know what
drives value, cash flows, growth and
risk. So the question you're asking
is what do you think a stock split does
to your value?
What is a stock split, Michael? Yeah,
it's basically when you uh reduce the
fights for pair. No, no, you don't do
any of that. So, you don't control it,
right? You just change the share count
two for one. So, the market will adjust
the price per share. So, basically, all
you've done in a stock split is change
the number of units in the company. Can
make you a more valuable company? No.
Otherwise, I'd be splitting my stock and
reverse splitting my stock. No. But
could it affect the price of the
company? Now, you see why the advantage
of talking about value and price is
separate issues. Why might it affect
price? Because I split the stock. You
might see signals in it. A 10 for one
stock split. That must mean great things
are going to happen. Therefore, I'll
push up the price. It doesn't affect
value, but it could affect price.
Advertising goodwill or impairing
goodwill is the current terminology puts
it. First, remember goodwill gets
created when you do an acquisition and
it's a difference in market value and
book value, right?
So that shows them the until
1999 that goodwill was automatically
advertised over 40
years. Starting in 1999 the rules
change. What are the current rules on
goodwill? Somebody with an accounting
basis can probably fill me in. What what
am I required to
do? And what does that mean? Impairment
testing. Who does it? So you need to
who's you right? I mean the does the
company do it or do they hire outsiders
to do it? Usually an Ernston Young Deote
a big chunk of what appraisal companies
make as value comes from this job cuz
it's a it's like taking Zerek. I take
Zerek I can never get off it because you
try to get off it your whole body starts
itching. I'm kind of stuck with it for
the rest of my life. This is like, you
know, because and so the accountants
will show up and then they will do a
little dance and charge you a hefty fee
and they say you're okay in which case
the goodwill stays on or you're not okay
in which case it's always one-sided.
They don't let you raise goodwill. And
this is the accounting mindset working
right now conservative. And why might
they impair Goodwill? What drives
goodwill impairment?
The value overpaid for the pricing has
changed. So if you bought a software
company and software companies are down
40% since you bought
them there will be an impairment of
goodwill is it so will that affect value
will it affect
earnings clearly the impairment will
reduce earnings but we care about cash
flows right in value for it to affect
cash flows what has to be true
it has to be tax deductible because then
it affects your cash flows 95% of
Goodwill impairment has no effect on
taxes. Which raises an interesting
question. Why the heck are we paying
Ernston Young millions of dollars to
change something that nobody cares
about? But that's a different story for
a different person to
answer. Advertising goodwill has zero
effect on value because it doesn't
affect the tax. It doesn't affect Could
it affect price? Maybe. Maybe people get
surprised. So, oh my god, they did a bad
acquisition. Let's lower the price. It
might raise price for all you know. It
doesn't affect what about changing the
because many US companies maintain two
sets of books. One for their reporting.
This is what you see when they put out
an earnings release and one for taxes.
It's completely legal to do in the
US. And they use different depreciation
methods sometimes in the two. So let's
say you've been using straight line
depreciation in both books and you
decide to switch to accelerated
depreciation just in your reporting
books. Strange thing to do, right?
Because usually the reverse happens.
Will that affect
values? What's the effect of
depreciation? It's on your taxes, right?
What's the only book that matters when
it comes to depreciation? Then the tax
books. You can do all kinds of dances.
You can go from straight line to
accelerated, from capitalizing to
expensive. But if you're doing it only
in your reporting books, it has zero
effect on
value. And 90% of the time when you see
these games played, it's entirely on the
reporting
books. Issuing tracking stock. I'm going
to replace the social media with AI. So
let's say you are a company, you have an
AI business. Tracking stock allows you
to kind of separate the business. not
legally because you still own the
business and issue it against AI. You
say, "Why would I do that?" During the
com boom, lots of companies
created tracking
stock and that stock zoomed because it
was do New York
Times.com briefly a tracking
stock. Is it changing any aspect of your
company? But could it affect price?
Yeah.
So much of what companies do and markets
react to are not driven by changes in
value. They're affect they ch the
changes in pricing. There are lots of
things companies do to affect their
price. But from a value perspective, you
look and say not interested. I don't
care. It'll make your life a lot easier
because you're not getting distracted by
a hundred different items that get
pulled in different you get pulled in
different directions. So the next
earnings report you say and you're going
to see a bunch in the next two weeks.
Separate the stuff that matters from the
fluff, right? There's going to be a lot
of fluff in these
reports. Now let's carry this to next
step. Let's say you become the new CEO
of a multi- business company, right?
It's got four divisions and you see them
listed
out. And as the new CEO, you're thinking
about selling one of these divisions.
Why? because you're the new CEO, you
want to show that you have power. Which
of these four divisions, which of these
four divisions, selling it would give
you the most potential for value
enhancement?
Nikita, you want to try D. And that's
what we're all trained to do in business
school, right? Why did you pick D? It's
a really bad business, right? That's
what we're all taught to do. Get rid of
your bad business. But what is the value
effect of dvestature?
It's what you get in return when you
devest, right? You have a bad business.
You're trying to sell it. Does everybody
know it's a bad business? I think so.
So, the price you're going to get is
going to come from people who who say
this is a bad business. They're not
paying you book value. If they did, you
would get rid of every bad business.
They're going to pay you based on what
this business is
generating. The effect of a devestature
is not whether a business is good or
bad. what you get for that business
relative to what it's worth to you as a
continuing business. Remember that bad
business is not money losing. It's just
making really low
profits. It has value to you. It's much
lower than your book value. But if
people pay less than that, you will
actually destroy value. And here in lies
one of the great ironies when you're a
multi-business company. You have seven
businesses. You know which business
you're most likely to enhance value by
selling your star business. Why? Because
people are enamored. They might pay more
than what that business is worth to you.
It cuts against every
grain of your being, right? So I want to
keep the best businesses. I want to get
rid of the Hey, you can do that. But if
your objective is value enhancement, you
want to take that AI business that is
your star business and sell it now
because you're more likely to see
somebody overpay for that business.
Yes, Michael. Like what about the fact
that your business could be driving
crosselling to business A? Like how do
we bring that into people? Well, you
could I mean then move some of the
earnings from business A and so once you
open the door, I'm going to make you
walk through and say, "Okay, tell me how
much of the revenues in business A come
from having business D and let's do a
fair but and that's an allocation
judgment." And after you've done that,
you still get back to which one should I
devest? And that boils down to very
simple comparison. What is it worth as a
continuing business to me? And what will
somebody pay me for that?
Right?
So lost my page here. Let me go back.
Sorry. So let's go back to where I left
you on synergy. Right? I gave you a very
simple example of synergy. You had um
you know Proctor and Gamble by Gillette
and we talked about a best case
valuation of synergy. We take a second
example. Let's assume your Best Buy,
right? And this was when Best Buy was
still a relatively healthy I think it
remains among at least electronic
retailers as healthy as you can get. And
let's say that you're interested in
buying Zenith. Zenith used to be a
legendary brand name in TV, but all it
has left, its biggest asset is that has
a big net operating loss. This is how
low it's fallen. You're buying it
because it has an NOL of $2
billion. So all you're buying is an NOL
with the name Zenith attached to
it. If your tax rate is
36%. What's the value you create by
buying this NOL?
The benefit of an N oil is you save
taxes. 36% of 2 billion 720 million.
Right? Let's make this a little more
interesting. To claim that 2 billion as
a tax benefit, you need 2 billion
operating income. Right? Let's say your
operating income is only a half a
billion a
year. Will you still
get the 720 million? You will, but
spread out over four years, right? 180
million each year for the next four
years. I have a very simple mechanical
question. To value the 180 million every
year for the next four years, I need a
discount rate, right? What discount rate
should I use to get the present value of
the tax benefits spread out over time?
I'll give you the choices. You can use
cost of equity or cost of
capital. You can use the acquiring
company or the target company, which is
Zen at the Best Buy.
You have four choices, right? Which
which discount rate should you use?
Not 100% sure, but I think cost of
capital of Best Buy. Reason through you,
you have the answer, but reason through
the you can use cost of capital or cost
of equity. I think you can make an
argument for either. How would how would
you approach answering the question
about discount rate? What do you have to
ask? Where does the risk come from here?
The risk here is not at the NOL. It's 2
billion. It's given. It's nothing to do
with Zenith, right? Zenith's left the
room. It has everything to do with
whether Best Buy will have enough
taxable income every year for the next
four years to claim the benefit. Taxable
income is actually equity income, right?
It's after interest expenses. So the
cost of equity perhaps is the best
choice. I can live with cost of capital
if you adjust your cost of debt somehow
for the tax benefits potentially being
lost. But whenever you have a question
about what discount rate to use, go back
to that question. Where is the risk here
coming from? Because that's usually
going to give you a sense of cost of
equity or cost of capital which company.
So here I would use Best Buy's cost of
equity because I think the risk I face
is my taxable income could end up not
being there in which case I'll lose the
tax
benefits. I've seen people use cost of
debt. I've seen people use the risk-free
rate and I don't quite get that right
because this is not guaranteed. The IRS
doesn't mail you a check for $180
million every year for the next four
years. It really depends on your
income. So with synergy I you know the
canard about synergy is in finance we
think synergy is worth nothing. That's
not true. Synergy can be worth a lot but
you have to go beyond the buzzword. You
got to tell me where the synergy is so I
can start to estimate it. And it's
amazing how managers are reluctant to
give you details probably because they
want to use it as a buzz word. It's so
much
easier. So you need specifics. And the
advantage of specifics, it comes with
two consequences. It comes with a plan,
right? Cuz once you give me specifics,
you know what to do after you've done
the merger. Synergy doesn't show up
magically. You got to work at it. And by
having the
specifics, you can start to plan for it
and you can hold people accountable. And
that's part of the problem as to why
people don't want to give you specifics.
Every acquisition within a company, if
you work in acquiring company, there
somebody's an advocate for the
acquisition. They're very much in favor
of it. They push the acquisition. They
hire the bankers. They get the deal
done. And often they overestimate the
benefits because they want the
acquisition to go through. You want to
reduce that bias. There's a very simple
t trick you can pull off. Take that
person and say, "Okay, you you really
believe this acquisition. you can be in
charge of it. And by the way, we're
going to take these numbers you're using
to sell us on this acquisition and
you're going to be responsible for
delivering these numbers and all of a
sudden you'll start to see those numbers
become more conservative because now
that those numbers actually have to be
delivered by somebody saying maybe I
should be using a 30% higher growth rate
after the
merger. And I've separated control from
synergy, right? I did it in two steps.
And I would strongly advise doing it in
two steps. Because all too often you see
people talking about control issues and
synergy. Control as value, synergy as
value. Why do I keep them separate?
Because the way I negotiate for each is
going to be very different. With
control, I always have a weaker hand to
play as the acquirer. Why? Because the a
target company can do it itself, right?
So if my control issue is if I ran this
company I would use more debt and take
fewer projects. The existing management
if it put its mind to it can do it. I
mean right now they're not doing it but
now that you've given them them the idea
they can do it themselves. So with
control I'm going to try to get a slice
but it's not going to be 80% or 90%.
With synergy you need both companies as
part of the deal. Right? And you want to
negotiate for a fair share. What did
what did determine a fair share? 50/50
60 40 80
20 and there synergy two sides
contribute right do they both contribute
the same amount in some days the
acquiring company strengths might be the
rarer strengths in which case you say
look without me you're not going to get
the synergy
elsewhere in some cases the target
company strength maybe they have this
great product that with capital can be
used much better right there the target
company has the advantage but you at
least have to try Because if you don't
try, then you're going to see what
actually happens in acquisitions. You
pay 120% of control and 150% of synergy.
And then you wonder what went
wrong. Let's talk about
pricing. There is an M&A class right in
at Stern. Did Did anybody take that
class?
Did you do pricing of target companies
in there or did you talk about
acquisition multiples? Yeah. Yeah. And
often I mean it's clearly not being
wasn't a memorable class because I would
hope but in a sense when you when you
see you know when you see pricing
applied in acquisition plays out in a
very simple way. Usually the bankers
will look at other M&A deals that have
been done. So it's not a pricing in the
conventional sense to value software
company. They look at all software
companies that's not what get they look
at a subset of software companies were
acquired. So that becomes a sample and
they do a bunch of multiple. So
basically they come up with a let's say
five times EBIT. Your target company is
20 million in EBIT. You apply that
multiple and you pay for it because
that's what other people there's a logic
to this right after all M&A is a deal
making process and to get deals done you
got to pay a price not a value.
Is it okay to use a pricing? I I think
so. Right. But if you're buying a
company for its cash flows and you keep
paying based on pricing, you can see the
danger here, right? Which is just
because at least as a trader, you have a
choice of getting out. You buy at a low
price and then sell at a high price.
You're acquiring the company. You have
it for the long term. I would think you
would be driven by intrinsic value. But
if you're really focused on dealing,
you're going to use
pricing. But if I were me, I would push
back and say, I am getting the cash
flows by acquiring the company. I want
to see what the intrinsic values and
based on it. And I'm going to push back
against the pricing. And you you know
what you're going to do? You say, what
if I do it in year five or year 10? This
is the terminal value calculation. And
that's how bankers end up using pricing
in the terminal value and make it look
like you're doing an intrinsic
valuation. Along the way though, I tried
to push you to get this deal done by
mentioning that it's accretive. Most
dangerous word in M&A is the word
accretive. Adil, what does a creative
mean? You're going to M&A, so you're
going to use that word a lot. So tell me
what a creative is.
Company and then affects your earnings.
So ETS
doesn't even have let's not even bring
PE and creative deal makes your earnings
per share go up after the deal. There
are two ways you can make your deal a
creative. One is to buy a company with a
lower P than yours. Mathematically
that's going to be a creative. What's
the
other? What is it earnings? It's
earnings per share, right?
If I borrow money and do the acquisition
almost by definition that deal is going
to be a creative rel you can see that a
creative is completely meaningless as a
measure of deal quality because if it
were a measure of deal quality that good
deals are a creative then I would just
buy companies with PE ratio lower than
mine. Think of how many companies Nvidia
could buy and all of them would be a
creative and borrow money till the cows
come home and every deal is a creative
and that's good as well. It's
absurd. But again, it's amazing how
often you see that word pop up. So with
pricing, I don't have a problem. But
with acquisition pricing, using these
other companies that when acquisitions
creates a bias sample, it's a
statistical problem. Do you see what the
bias is? We talked about how people
overpay in acquisitions, right? You take
a sample of companies involved in
acquisitions, you are in fact looking at
a sample where people
overpay. It's a biased sample. And if I
let you use whatever multiple you want
to, you can go find a multiple with that
bias sample that pretty much justifies
any deal you want to do. And pushing it
out to year five or year 10 doesn't make
the problem go away. It just delays
dealing with the
problem. So in M&A, you're going to see
a lot of pricing. And I would push at
least for statistical honesty. You want
to price your company target company
rather than based on based on this this
pure group of acquired companies. Look
at the entire beer group. Am I paying
too much for this company? So you want
to play the pricing game at least play
it you know correctly. Play it play play
it
honestly. So if you were to, you know,
if you decide to go go along with
pricing, no, be very clear about the
fact that you've picked the pricing game
over the value game. And as an acquirer,
that does expose you to risk. Second,
don't get distracted by things like
accretion. They're completely irrelevant
in this process. Accretion, delusion, I
don't care. In fact, McKenzie did a
study of accretive deals versus dilutive
deals and track them over time. And I
found actually dilutive deals did better
than accreative deals after the fact.
And if you're interested, go on to the
Mackenzie quarterly. You can pull up
that study. So next time somebody brings
a creative versus dilutive and you're
doing a pricing, at least do an honest
price,
right? But now comes my trump card. So
far, you've been very resistant, right?
You're that that sensible guy in the in
the acquiring company says, "No, I won't
use your my cost of equity. I won't use
my cost of debt." So at every stage
you've been resistance. So I hit you
with what I think is something you can't
overcome. I tell you look, you do know
your CEO really, really, really wants to
get this deal done, right? And that's in
fact something that you know that that
many deals we got to be honest
about. And by the way, I can get you a
banker to sign a ferous opinion that
this deal is actually worth. So what am
I offering you here? First is I'm saying
if you don't do this your boss is going
to replace you with somebody else. And
second I'm offering you legal cover
which is you're worried about paying too
much. Don't worry you cannot get
sued because I've got a fairness opinion
signed by Goldman
Sachs. It is it is the reality that we
face and it's something that often I
mean let's face you have a job. You want
to hold on to the job and I'm making you
pick between holding on to the job and
kind of bending it a little bit so you
can get deals now. You can see how bad
it's not a question of people not having
ethics and this is really a question of
hey survival is key here. I've got to do
what I need to do.
There's one final dimension in
acquisitions which I which can get you
into into into a fair amount of trouble
which is I tell you look all your
competitors are doing deals and if you
don't do a deal you're going to be left
in the core. These are called defensive
acquisitions. In other words, if you
don't do this acquisition your eight
competitors are going to consolidate
become three and you're going to be the
outlier.
Technically, you could do cash flows to
say, "Hey, you know what? The cash flows
I would lose by not doing this deal are
greater than what I pay as a premium.
So, I'm going to do the
deal." As you do that though, there are
there are a couple of things. So, first,
you know, let's deal with the fact that
your CEO really wants to do it. There is
there is evidence that that when you
look at acquiring companies, the common
feature you see across acquiring
companies are overconfident
CEOs. Okay? Overconfidence behavioral
finances. So overconfident CEOs take
this acquisition gene from company to
company and in many cases they're driven
by that overconfidence leads them to
believe they can deliver the synergy. So
basically they pay up front say I'm
smart enough I can pull off adding an
extra half a billion. So that's that's a
and the ego comes into play as well
because when you lose a deal it becomes
a reflection on who you are as a serial.
I think a lot of what happens in M&A is
kind of a case study of behavioral
finance and how the psychology of
winning and losing drive especially
because you're spending other people's
money. And as for their defensive
mergers, I understand it. I understand
the me tooism is going to drive that.
But if the only way you can survive in a
business is by doing bad acquisitions,
what does it tell you about the nature
of this business? It's not a good
business to be in. So for the moment, do
whatever you need to do, but think of
ways of exiting this business or
shrinking because you're probably doing
a service to your investors by becoming
smaller over time.
Yeah, there's an argument
about your business. You're in a bad
business, maybe you shouldn't be
replaced. Let's say you're in the
theater business. Do I really want to
replace the 300 theaters that AMC has?
Maybe the business has changed to the
point that people are not going to the
theater anymore. So understand
replacement value assumes the core
demand for this business is there right
in which case you pay the replacement
cost. So the notion of replacement cost
makes sense only in a business where you
think that that demand will exist. So
maybe with an airline you can say look
I'm going to get the routes and the
planes because people will need to fly
from point A to point B. But in other
businesses you look and say this is a
bad business needs to get smaller.
So if there's a lesson out of this one
is if you define your objective in an in
an acquisition as winning a bidding war,
you will win, right? All you have to do
is what? Pay more than the next best
bidder. It's the win classic winner's
curse in auctions, right? And as you
look at this, the premiums you pay for
synergy, for control, you know, or
whatever else, they they have to have
something real. It can't just be know
something that reflects the c the ego of
the CEO saying look I want to get the
deal
done and defensive mergers are a sign of
business weakness and you might want to
ask is this a business that's turned bad
or is it if it's temporary then I can
understand you want to defensive merge
you want to stay on but otherwise you're
really pushing the limits on what M&A
can do for
you and finally I said this at the start
The problem I have with M&A is when
deals fall apart, as they so often do,
nobody seems to be held
responsible. It's almost like a big deal
as a thousand fathers, parents, whatever
it is, and deal falls apart. It's an
orphan. I wasn't there. Who the heck did
this deal? Seemed there were no bankers,
no managers involved. So, I'll give you
an example. Okay, I think I might have
used this example in corporate finance
as well, but I will do it again. This
was actually a deal that Huelet Packer
did to buy this Britishbased software
business services company called
Autonomy. Okay, so the company the so
Hullet Pack had actually paid 11.1
billion on the deal and this actually
gives you how they got to the 11 1
billion how they justified it. So
basically they started with the pre-deal
book equity. The publicly traded company
started with that. They first hired a
bunch of accountants to come in and
reappraise existing value which pushed
up the book equity. So that's a little
bit of writing up. The market attached a
premium on top of it. So this is a
company that was trading at 5.9 billion
at the time they did this deal but they
justified paying an extra 5.2 billion.
That's almost an 80 80% 85% premium by
using all the magic. What? There's
synergy. There's control. we can run the
company
better. So that was the deal being done.
Usually deals take a while to fall
apart. But at the time that this deal
was done, Mark Herd was the CEO of you
know the the Leo I'm sorry, Leopico
would been hired as a CEO to replace
Mark Herd who' been fired because of
sexual in indiscretion in the office
place or something. So this is a company
that already had top management moving
along was in front of a group of equity
research analysts in New York City. Now
I'm going to read the words he used his
words so I can't be accused of putting
words in his mouth. So at the time this
deal got done the premium was so big
that this was one of those few case
where everybody was skeptical. The
competitors were skeptical. Equity
research analysts were skeptical. So Leo
shows up in front of a group of equity
research analysts and he tries to
explain to them why they paid the
premium. He says we have a pretty
rigorous process inside HP that we
follow in our acquisitions which is a D.
C.F base model. I'd love to see that D.
C.F base. I don't know what the basis is
and it's either a DCF model or it's not
but it's based on a DCF I guess. And he
kept going and we tried to take a very
conservative view. Okay. Right. And then
he kept going even further. He said just
to make sure everybody understands
autonomy will be on day one
finish. Okay, we got that out of the
way. Just take it from us. We pay did
that analysis at great length in great
detail. Lots of great popping up here
and we feel we paid a very fair price
for autonomy. It will give a great
return for our shareholders.
I don't know how many people he
convinced, but this deal fell apart in
record time. A year later, HP took a
right down of $8.8
billion. Part of it they blamed on bad
accounting practice and autonomy. So, at
the time the deal fell apart, I decided
this is a bad deal. I'm going to hold
people accountable. So, I started
divvying up the $ 8.8 $8 billion write
down in terms of who was responsible for
which spot. So I started with
non-existent synergy. The synergy never
showed up and said hey you can't blame
accounting for that. you just there was
no synergy and I blamed the pre at that
time Leoar had been replaced as a CEO
and you know and a new CEO had come in
and I said the existing management I did
say there was some accounting mis
misdemeanors at the target company and I
attached that to the the deote which was
their auditor saying you
miss and then there was a remaining
write off where you could just say that
HP's management has to be responsible.
So essentially there's a lot of blame,
right? Bankers,
accountants, you know how many people
lost their jobs because of this deal?
None. You know how much fee got returned
as the deal fell apart?
Nothing. And that to me is at the core
of this problem. When you have bad
deals, how come no one is being held
responsible and allowed to kind of walk
away from these deals? So collectively,
this is a pretty negative assessment
I've given of acquisitions, right? Some
of you are going to end up in M&A. So
I'm going to give you this glimmer of
hope as to where there might be a
possibility of actually creating value
from deals. And you're going to help me
because I'm going to structure in terms
of where do you think the chances of
creating value? So think purely in terms
of value. We're not interested in the
pricing game. We want to create value.
So I'm going to give you
choices. You're in acquisition. Would
you rather be a Let's start easy. Would
you rather be a soul bidder or in a
bidding war?
And if you're in a bidding war, would
you ra like to win the bidding war or
lose the bidding war?
In fact, I'm going to show some very
interesting evidence of what happens to
bidding winners and bidding losers.
Second, if you have two targets, one is
a publicly traded company, the other is
a privatelyowned business, where are
your odds of creating value greater and
why?
I'm sorry. private. Tell me why. Why
with the private business do you have
great odds
and what do you negotiate from? What's
your starting point when you negotiate?
You can tell that you know you don't get
acquired by publication. No, but it's a
public company. There's a starting
point, right? Below which you can't go.
What's the starting point? Market price,
right? You start market price and you
negotiate up from that which already
puts you at a disadvantage because who
knows what the market is already
incorporating it. With a private
business you're negotiating from a value
you estimate which could be a total beta
liquidity discountbased value. At least
it gives you a shot. Would you rather
pay with cash or pay with stock? This is
a tricky word Michael about what your
stock is doing. Depends on what your
stock is doing but it turns out that so
play it through. So if your stock is
overpriced, if my stock is overpriced, I
want to pay with stock. Let's pause
right there. So you pay with stock. I'm
the target company shareholder. I notice
you're paying with stock. Do I read
things into that?
So I'm going to start you see how this
game plays out, right? The premium. So
people, you know, companies that have
high share prices feel this in but it's
not a slam dunk because if the premium
goes up enough to reflect that, you very
quickly start to lose that advantage,
right?
Small target versus large target. Would
you prefer to do a merger of equals or a
merger of unequals?
Small target. Tell me what happens when
a large company buys another large
company. Yeah. Usually both. It's like
two elephants mating. It is a messy
messy process. Right. I mean I I don't
know whether you've ever worked at a
company after an
acquisition. Two large companies the
culture clash. I mean I I remember know
talking to somebody at Chrysler after
they got bought by D and said how are
things going and he said not well there
language issues their culture issues
with very different cultures the entire
books written about these so small how
about synergies would you prefer to go
for cost synergies or growth
synergy cost synergies are more tangible
you can plan for them you're more likely
to show up so let's see if the evidence
backs you up I'm going to start with
bidding war findings. So let's say you
enter into a bidding war. There's a
winner or a loser, at least the Wall
Street Journalist tells you, based on
who wins the deal, right? This is a
graph where one of these lines tells you
what happens to stock
price of a company. And so which one do
you think goes with the winner here? We
think of winners as company. There's the
winner right there. There's the
loser. If you're in a bidding
war, hope and pray. If you're in
stockholder in a company in a bidding
war, hope and pray that your company
loses the bidding
war. It's more likely that it stock
price will go up in the months after
than the company that wins the bidding
war. It's tough to do though, right?
Because you got to walk away from the
deal. Second, when you look at small
versus large targets, it is tough. It's
a tough graph to read. I basically have
so these are the the blue is the
smallest targets. The purple is the
largest targets across the board. You
can see purple does worse except in
entirely cashbased
deals. The larger a deal becomes, the
more difficult it becomes to use stock
and get away with that deal because this
gaming process plays out more. But given
a choice, small deals over large deals.
private versus public targets. And I've
added a third group, divisions of public
companies that are being sold off. And
the results here are actually
interesting. Private beats public. It's
so it's better. But divisions of public
companies are even better targets than
private businesses. Why might that be?
Because that first table I showed you,
right? You were the CEO. What we what
was in get rid of that bad division at
what price? Doesn't matter. just get rid
of it. This is the best possible target
for me because you're just giving away
the
stuff. Automotives has been saved by an
acquisition it did in 2009 of Jaguar
Land Rover. And Ford was so focused on
getting rid of Jaguar Land Rover that
they basically sold it at a below
bargain basement price because it's the
one to get it off their
books. So, is there a way to create
value? Clearly, there is. But you
things like core and noncore businesses
which the conglomerate want to get out
of the noncore business. So that's
different though, right? I mean if your
non-core businesses are badly managed
and badly run, you might be able to get
them at that badly managed badly run
price and fix them, right? So I mean
it's the the same argument will hold
which is you no longer have a market
price to worry about, right? as your
starting point. You're estimating the
value. And as a negotiator, you're going
to say, I'm going to start with your bad
operations and value based on that. Cost
synergies, growth synergies is from a
McKenzie study that looked at what it
breaks down and emerges based on what
the original synergy motor was and then
looks at what what number of companies
actually deliver on what they promised
up front. So there's your cost
synergies, right? Out of the 92
companies, 36% actually 36 of the 92
actually delivered more in savings than
they told you up front. And in fact, the
median number is about 80 to 90%. So
most of the cost synergies got
delivered. There's growth
synergies. You can see how much more
spread out it is and how many had
delivered less than 30% of what they
thought they could get up. And the
reason I think is simple. Growth
synergies people don't plan for. They
just talk about big things. We're going
to enter a new market. We're going to
produce a new product. And because they
do that, there's nothing in place for it
to actually come into
being. So the bottom line is if you want
to be an acquisitive company and you
want to grow through acquisitions, you
have to start off by accepting that this
is a more difficult path historically
than growing
organically. But if you decide to go
down that path, there is a pathway to
creating value, but it requires you stay
disciplined.
What does that mean? You buy small
companies, you change how they run and
that's your modus operandi. Small
private companies, you stay with that.
The only problem is this strategy comes
with the clock, right? As you do this
and you get more successful, you're
getting bigger as a company. As you get
bigger as a company, what do you have to
do? You have to do more of these deals.
And you're going to start to get tempted
to go for bigger deals cuz the $10
million deals you were really good at
are not making a debt. If you read the
history of Cisco, you can see this
process play out. 92 Cisco was a small
company. Amazing in terms of doing
deals, right? It had a SWAT team that
would land in a target company, change
the entire company's product because it
basically bought companies with
promising products that hadn't quite
found a market. It was amazing at
finding that market. Between 92 and
1999, its market cap went from 4 billion
to 400 billion. There's a brief moment
in 99. most highly highest market cap in
the world built around this model. And
then you look at the next decade though
and we looked at this in the in the cont
the entire process unraveled. It's
discipline sometimes means knowing when
to stop which is we become too big. We
can't adopt the strategy. It's really
really difficult to pull that off. If
you're in a bidding war just drop out.
It's easier said than done because egos
get involved. But you know, if you look
at the return to your shareholders, it
almost never wins. Try to hold people
accountable, preferably the person who's
pushing hardest for the acquisition,
right? Say, okay, you think that's a
great deal. You power enough to push it
through, you're going to be accountable
for it. And finally, I think we have to
figure out a way we'd have clawbacks of
compensation when deals. I mean, you're
a deal advisor. You advise me to pay $50
billion more than I
should. What kind of deal advice is
that? And why am I paying you $150
million for that advisory fee?
Right? So, work in progress, but you can
see that the way we do M&A now is not
working.
Singapore is experimenting with setting
up a process that is less biased where
deal making is going to be separated
from deal analysis. A banker will not be
allowed to analyze a deal if he's the
deal. You still have the problem bankers
will scratch each other's back. So if
you're Goldman Sachs, maybe Morgan
Stanley will come into it. But at least
it's the start in the process because we
need to kind of attack that core
problem. Any questions at all about
acquisition? So know I've often been
asked why I don't do an M&A valuation
class and I say it'll last about 45
minutes and then I run out of there's
nothing unique about you can't change
the rules of valuation just because
you're doing an acquisition control and
synergy obviously come up but there's
still about cash flows growth and risk
right so keep your focus on those basics
and sometimes you can look at practice
and say that doesn't make sense so let's
talk about value enhancement. The last
piece of this class, I first want to
draw a contrast between value
enhancement and price enhancement
because most of the time when CEOs talk
about wanting to increase their value,
you know what they really want to do,
right? They want to increase the price.
Why? Because compensation types the
price, options types the price. I'll
give you my favorite example for the
contrast between value enhancement and
price enhancement.
the late 90s, the peak of the dot boom,
a couple of researchers wrote a paper
called a rose by any other name. They
looked at, I think, 60 to 65
companies that change their name in a
very specific way. What do you think
they
did? Boom. Everybody's they added to
their name. But these companies changed
nothing about their businesses. There's
some companies that added and changed
their business model. these companies.
So you are a steel making company. You
just added com to your name and you kept
making
steel. You know the value effect here,
right? Is changing your name has no
effect on cash flows, growth and risk.
It shouldn't affect value. That was
easy. But this study looked at what
happened the stock price of these
companies when they added.com to the
next. These were many of them were small
companies. On average, the stock price
doubled when you put.com. I'm seeing a
lot of companies add AI to their names.
Have you noticed
this? You can see the pull, right? You
think this is great. Why do we spend 15
weeks talking about cash flows, growth,
and risk? We should have been
experimenting with different naming
conventions. But there's a catch to this
problem to this to this approach. Two
years later, the.com boom
bust and having.com in your name
became a problem. So, another study in
2004 looked at companies that change the
names. Guess what they did? They
took.com out of their names, stock price
source. Again, this is a perfect example
of pricing at play, right? You name it,
you take the name out, you put the name
back in. And you can see already why you
can't play this game long term because
it is whatever the market is in the mood
for and that could change overnight and
you're running your company trying to
keep the market happy. It never ends
well. I was watching um you know Michael
Sailor Micro Strategy guy. You know it's
absurd how people end up running
multi-billion dollar companies. This
guy's running this basically receptacle
for Bitcoin. You're betting on Michael
Sailor getting the Bitcoin price
convention right. He's describing what
he called his business model. If you get
a chance, watch it on CNBC. It's almost
terrifying that he got tens of billions
of dollars riding on this model. You
borrow money, you buy Bitcoin, Bitcoin
goes up, you borrow more money. He said,
"This is like arbitrage." I said, "No,
that's a very strange definition of
arbitrage because know you found a way
for the risk to go away. How the heck
did that happen?" Yes. then he gave was
on the crypto exchanges people are
scared of buying crypto so they would
rather buy the shares but still become
but you're paying a premium on the
bitcoin right that's the question so if
you just paid for the bitcoin so you're
take you're paying 195,000 per bitcoin
you have to be terrified to double the
price you pay that's an insane way to
create a so think of this as a closed
end fund to buy bitcoin and bitcoin only
and that's basically what you have in
the Right. So, let's talk about true
value enhancement. And none of what I'm
going to say is going to sound
unfamiliar. For the value of a business
to change, it's got to show up somewhere
in the numbers, right? So, you can
increase your value by increasing your
cash flows from existing assets. By
doing what? By cutting cost, being more
efficient. You can increase value by
from growth in one of two ways. If
you're in a good business, by
reinvesting more. But if you're in a bad
business, you know how you increase the
value from growth? By reinvesting less.
So both
compare. If you're a company with very
few competitive advantages, the way it
shows up is I can't give you excess
returns for very long. You very quickly
become a mature company. Your return on
capital goes to your cost of capital. So
maybe a third way is you build
competitive advantages, barriers to
entry. Maybe this is a use for your
corporate strategy class because if that
is what class is about is what are the
potential competitive advantages, you
can build on those or you can try to
reduce your cost of capital by doing
what? You can change the mix of debt and
equity. You can also change the type of
debt you use to fund your assets. And
we'll come back to that because matching
debt to your assets reduces your default
risk and your cost to capital.
Ultimately, all restructuring has to go
through one or more of these pathways.
So, let's take each one and let's talk a
little bit about the pluses and minuses.
So, let's talk about increasing cash
flows from assets inputs. So, I'll go
through the the words that you usually
hear in study. There's going to be a lot
of cost cutting.
assuming you mean what you say. And the
reason I say assuming what you say is a
lot of companies announce with a lot of
fanfare they're going to cut cost, but
you track them two years later, they
haven't really cut money in cost. You
know, they've cut these pennies, but the
dollars are still there. But assuming
what I hear is higher margins, higher
earnings, higher cash flows, but I'm
also going to look at what cost you cut.
If the cost you're cutting as a
technology for is R&D, that's really
fake cost cutting, right? because you
took your capex which happen to be mis
miscatategorized and you got it. So we
know cost cutting can shop so it clearly
can so we'll talk about value in but
cost cutting clearly is is an easy
component to you put into the
margins at the risk of sounding
unpatriotic. I don't think it should be
the objective of any company to maximize
taxes paid to the government. Before you
beat me up though I'm legally you want
to minimize your taxes paid. I'm not
talking about tax evasion. I'm talking
about what's avoid that tax law tax
avoid tax management. Let's call it tax
man. That sounds good. What are some of
the things you can do to reduce taxes
paid? I mean, if you're a multinational,
I mean, I think the entire reason for
transfer pricing existing as a
profession is to move income from high
tax locals to low tax. might be a very
cynical view of transfer pricing but you
want to reduce your taxes paid shows up
as a lower T higher after tax operating
income if you have maintenance capex
maintaining your existing assets if you
can make that lower holding olives
constantly increase your cash flows from
existing assets and I'm not talking
about the capex for growing this is the
capex to maintain your existing
assets and finally if you're a company
that has very heavy working capital
needs reducing that working capital will
increase your cash flows as
So you can try to increase cash flows
lots of different pathways. So when I
look at these announcements of we're
going after existing asset we're going
to make them clearly there can be value
enhancing actions where you cut costs
where you really don't get enough in
benefits reduce your taxes. So we can
make a list but you can also think about
cost cutting that on the at the first
site you think it's good but then you
take a deeper look and say this could
actually destroy value. I gave you the
example of cutting R&D expenses. You
might make it look like you've cut costs
and made yourself more profitable. But
if you're a growth company, you cut out
the heart of your value. It could be
that you pay less in taxes, but you use
some very questionable procedures that
are going to blow up in your face. So,
initially I give you a benefit, but then
I say, "Oh, maybe I should claw that
back because that's not going to be
there." Maybe you're not. You claim you,
you know, you're an airline and you
decide to cut back on maintenance capex
and you cut it back so much that your
air that your planes are no longer safe.
Then you got a problem. So I would say,
you know, what I'm trying to say is the
cosmetic cost cutting. We're going to
make our operation more efficient. I
hear it all the time. But then you take
a closer look, but twothirds of the time
you look at and say, "This is really not
value enhancement. It's cosmetic. It
makes it look like you're going to make
it." No, but you got to separate the two
sides. Now let's talk about this devest
abandon because you're looking at the
existing assets say which one should I
do? No, every asset you have as a
company has three measures of value. The
first is what I call continuing value
where you take the cash flows you would
get if you continue to hold this asset
discounted back at the right cost of
capital you come up with the value. The
second is an abandonment value which is
you shut the business down and you get
whatever salvage you get for the
physical assets. The third is
devestature value which is where you
sell the business to somebody else as a
going concern and they pay you what you
think it's worth. I mean I'll give you
the general rule for every asset you
should pick the one that gives you the
highest number and and and carry
through. It's kind of tricky, right?
because that means you're going to be
selling off piece of business that you
think are great because somebody's
willing to pay twice what it's worth.
But at least in a world where it's all
about value enhancement, that's
basically what's going to drive your
decision process. So that's why when you
looked at that initial example, I said
it's not the worst business that might
be the one that creates value. It's
devesting your very best
business, which brings me to growth. Now
most restructuring you see focus on we
want to increase growth. What do we I
mean if you're Bed Bath and Beyond,
you're in the new CEO. Would I be better
off? You're trying to grow it. Plus, I
mean, Starbucks now is in a place where
this is going to be the big choice,
right? I think the most sensible thing
for Starbucks to do is to shut down
about 25 to 30% of their stores,
preferably their most expensive stores,
which means in New York City, you have
to walk eight blocks instead of one
block to find the next Starbucks. I feel
really sorry for you, right? But let's
face it, that's a choice you have to
make. I don't know whether that's with
Intel. That's a question as well, right?
Should we go for more growth and try to
go after it or should we go for growth?
It really depends on what kind of
business you think you're in. Starbucks,
it's an interesting question. It's in a
saturated market. You're saying China,
but China, they're going after Luck and
Coffee as a competitor who cuts who
sells cappuccinos for half the price you
sell them for. I don't see easy value
enhancement left in Starbucks. In India,
they they have a joint venture. So
basically, they've lost control of that
component of the business anyway. The
joint venture might still make the
money. There's no easy pathways left for
growth. And if there are no easy
pathways, maybe the best thing to do is
to actually shrink as a company. Not
even reinvest less, but actually devest
yourself from those
leases. And remember that table I showed
you? percentage of companies globally
beat their cost to
capital like 30 to 40% beat that because
60 to 70% have trouble making the cost
to capital a lot more companies should
leave the door open to shrinking rather
than growing as the pathway to value and
answer keep your eye on the next CEO and
how many new CEOs talk about shrinking
businesses I almost never hear it happen
and that's troublesome because it's
almost like and I blame all of us right
from academia to practice is because we
glorify growth. We put on pedestals
people who make their companies bigger
and then we ring our hands about why
aren't these why are these companies
continuing to grow because that's what
we've told people is the better thing to
do. That's what good managers do, right?
So if your business is good and you can
reinvest more and grow at a higher rate,
all the more power to you. It might
require going out of your safe zone. So
maybe you're a US company, you've never
been over, you know, tried overseas,
then this might be the way you grow. But
if you're in a bad business, the way you
increase value is by reducing
growth. Now along the way, you'll have
lots of different pathways to growing,
right? In fact, this is from a McKenzie
study. And one of the advantages
McKenzie has is this proprietary
information on what clients at the
company have done over time. They hide
the names of clients. Obviously they
hide the confidential information but
they can do these studies of what have
companies tried and which ones have
worked the way. So this was from a study
that looked at growth and rank different
ways of growing from most value adding
to least value adding. Right? So take it
with a grain of salt because it's a
McKenzie sample. It's 40 years of
Mckenzie clients trying different
things. At the top of the list most
value creating growth strategy is to
come up with a new product.
Apple with the the iPad, the iPhone, I
mean recreated itself, right? The way to
read this, it's and I don't know why
Mackenzie did it this way. The way to
read it, this tells you how much value
is created for a million dollars
invested in that strategy. A million
dollars invested in creating new
products on average creates 1.75 to 2
million. But I did take a look at the
raw data and there is a tr troublesome
component to the raw data. You know what
what it is?
It's that 20% of new product strategies
succeed and they make huge it's a very
skewed distribution. the median is much
much lower right so it's a high payoff
strategy but it's a low it strategy
right think of how many new products
microsoft introduced me in 1990 2013
none of which took off second is
expanding an existing
market either geographically or finding
new
customers sometimes this happens by
accident as in the case of Novo Nordisk
you had a diabetes drug one day, the
next day you wake up, you've got a
weight loss drug, right? Huge jump in
value. There it was accidental, but
maybe you can try to reach for it. The
third is maintaining or growing your
market share in a growing market. It's
so much easier to create value when the
market you're going after is growing
than when it's
stagnant. An advantage that Indian
companies will have over European
companies right off the start. Right?
You got 50 million new people adding to
the middle class every year. That's a
market you can draw on to draw for
growth that you don't have. And now you
get to the bottom two. And here you can
see that the payoffs are becoming not
just lower, but they're becoming
negative. One is competing for share in
a stable
market. Morning in the corporate finance
class, we're talking about the
restaurant business in the US. Chipotle,
Cava, Cheesecake Factory. I mean that
was those are the companies that were
pay. US is a pretty saturated market in
terms of restaurants. If you're trying
for a higher market share there, it's
going to be challenging to create value
because how do you get a higher market
share? You got to cut prices. You cut
prices, you might get the higher market
share, but your margins go down. And if
they cut prices, too, then you got to
cut prices even more. This is like a
recipe for everybody going down the
drain.
And then at the very bottom of the list
and this should come as no surprise
after the last session and a half is
acquisitions. Yeah, I got a lot of heat
once for saying my my exit point for any
stock that I own is when it announces a
big
acquisition. To me, that is that's a
time to leave because it signals a lot
of different things, right? I've held
Apple for a long time. If Apple
announced a big acquisition, I'm
probably out of that door. Even though
it might be dressed up and look good for
the
moment, historically the payoff from
inorganic growth has always been lower
than the payoff to organic growth. Yes.
Going back to when you said if a company
don't have a clear path for growth, um
have you seen any companies that did a
pretty good job either managing the
shrinking or like the continuation? Very
few. Right? Because that and that's part
of the problem. Very few man. I think G
did a pretty good job at the end there.
You know, you got to give the, you know,
what was his name? The the last GE CEO.
Yeah. Now, Welch was the one who built
the the if this is notice the the CEOs
you need for declining companies. You'll
never read their names. They stay out of
the press. They have low profiles. If
you have a big ego, you will never
shrink your business, right? So if I
were a declining company, first thing I
would do is make sure that you're
picking somebody who comes in in
disguise and says, "I I don't want
anybody to see me. I don't want any
pictures." You know, it's tough to find
people like that who become CEOs, right?
We are, you know, we're in a world where
where we pick overconfident people as
CEOs, then we wonder why are they they
keep making big bad bets. It's their,
you know, it's what made them successful
in the first place, right? So I it's
very difficult to find good examples of
companies that have shrunk. I you know
one of my favorite examples is a Russian
steel company called
Severstar which between two it was a
company that grew to become a global
steel company. It was a publicly traded
company but run by an oligarch. That's
almost a given in any Russian company.
Even it's publicly traded there's
usually an oligarch at the top who kind
of pulls all the strings. But this was a
very competent ol oligarchs can be
competent as well, right? They didn't
get to be oligarchs by being completely
stupid. And in 2006, so he grew as a
steel business became a a great
business. But then in around 2007 or
eight, the steel business started to
turn bad and over the next decade
several shrunk its revenues by 50%. What
what he did actually was sell off all
his businesses outside Russia and went
back to his core business in Russia
where the margins were three times
higher than they were elsewhere because
no foreign steel company wanted to come
come in and compete with the steel
business. He did it because he was the
largest shareholder in the company. For
him it was his money at play. And maybe
that plays a big role in when you see
shrinkage. You're more likely to do it
if you think it's my money. I've got to
do something to protect it. I mean think
of how long Blockbuster hung around
right well after every everybody knew
the business had turned bad but they
kept opening new stores it's almost like
you're running on
autopilot let's talk about competitive
advantages I am not a corporate
strategist I have no desire to be a
corporate strategist but if you think
about it you know competitive advantages
play out in valuation all the time where
first in how much you earn over and
above the cost of capital remember the
value of growth comes from being able to
earn more than the cost capital. That's
a number, but it comes from some barrier
to entry. Amgen earns more than its cost
of capital. Why? Because it has patents
protecting it, right? Coca-Cola earns
well above its cost of capital. Why?
Because it has a brand name that gives
it pricing
power. So, if you're a company and you
have no competitive advantages, you're
at a disadvantage in terms of creating
value. So, you're going to try to create
a competitive advantage. You not always
succeed, but you try, right? And if you
have competitive advantages, they don't
exist forever if you don't defend
them. So this is of course warrant what
what's the word Warren Buffett and
traditional value investors use for
comparative advantages? Moes, right? So
basically we're measuring the width and
the depth of the moat and how long the
moat will stay in place.
So I decided to kind of look at you know
at different types of competitive modes
both in terms of you know and whether
the mode is wide narrow or whether
there's no more. So let's take brand
name right if you're a top brand you
obviously have one of the strongest
competitive brand it's long-term it's
sustainable. If you have a name brand
that people recognize your name but it's
not something that they're willing to
pay a higher price for. It's kind of in
the middle. And if you're a generic
there's no brand name value. So from
white to normal switching costs, you
know what switching costs
are? You want to make the cost of
switching into your product as low as
possible. And once people switch in, you
want to make the cost of switching out
as high as possible. Next time you
switch uh sell cell companies, the if
you come into a AT&T store, you know the
person who's most clamored after is a
Verizon customer who walks in. There'll
be like three salespeople around you. 15
minutes we can switch you to AT&T and
you make the mistake of actually going
along. 15 minutes later you've switched
but then they give you this 24page
document to sign. So what is this? Oh by
the way we didn't mention this but
you're now tied in for 24 months. We
have leans on your house, your firstborn
and your you know basically I mean but
think about it if you if you think about
the cell phone business there's there
should be no stickiness right you should
be able to so the only way they can
survive as businesses is by making the
business stickier they try sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't in fact their
favorite employees to offer you special
deals I've been getting I have an iPhone
10 AT&T knows it Every day I get an
offer. You can walk in and I'll we'll
give you a free iPhones. It's not free.
Basically, they switch the phone and
then tie me in for 24 months at $10 a
month. Another way of creating
stickiness. So, if you can create high
switching costs, no potentially wide,
but then you can see there's a
variation. Uber is trying in the right
sharing distance, right? We talked about
how much how little stickiness and
what's Uber doing? They've created Uber
one, a subscription service where you
pay
$9.99 a month. The usually when you
create these things, you worry about the
competitors doing it as well. You know
why Lyft can't do it? Why would you pay
$9.99 for one subscription but not for a
lift one subscription? It's
Jessica and she and also you get Uber
Eats for free, right? That gives them a
huge advantage because I mean if you're
doing Door Dash, it's already what?
$599.69. So you're paying for the
equivalent of Door Dash plus you get
these special deals. Lyft doesn't have a
food delivery service.
So you already see that this they're
trying. Will it work? I don't know. I
don't know. They haven't given full
statistics on how quickly it's growing.
They're getting a subset of people. But
that's a stickiness component.
Networking benefits. So, we've talked
about these, right? What's the essence
of a networking
benefit, right? Sharing had it, right?
As you get larger, it gets easier to get
larger because people want to be where
everybody else is. So, again, global
networking benefits strongest, you know,
big local networking benefits where you
get a particular city or region and if
they're
none cost advantages. It's nice if you
have a permanent cost advantage over
your competition. You think of a company
that has one. We've talked about
it. A
Ramco. This cost advantage is going
nowhere, right? It's nobody else is ever
going to get their oil out of the ground
at $6 a barrel or $8 a barrel per
minute. It can be
temporary. You know,
when compact started, they had a cost
advantage over
IBM. gave them this room to grow and
then Dell came along and compact lost it
and then Dell lost it comp cost
advantage Lenovo right that's temporary
you get a brief period of growth because
you have a cost advantage but it doesn't
last and finally it's nice if you can
get the government to protect you from
competition right which is effectively
what a patent does at least on the
product you have if it's full protection
you basically are a regulated
monopoly we'll talk about the the the
catch in them being a regulated
monopoly. But you can see that the
protection can vary. You say, "Okay, I'm
going to go to the government and become
a regulated monopoly." The phone
companies and the power companies got
protection, right? They But what were
they required to give up in
return? Think about what the great thing
about being a monopoly is. Nobody likes
you. But how do you get back at them?
You charge them more. You don't like me?
50% more. You're the phone company.
Nobody likes you. You go to charge them
50% more. What holds you back? You're
regulated. You can get a 3% increase.
It's the worst of all worlds. I'd rather
be in a competitive marketplace and
charge prices than be a regulated
monopoly. But no, if you're going to get
protection from the government, make
sure it doesn't come with this catchup.
You'll get the protection but no pricing
power. One of the biggest challenges in
the company is measuring that motor. We
really don't have I mean I know we use
the excess return but think of how
primitive that measure is. You use last
year's return on capital it's an
accounting number. You know Home Depot
might make it go up because they did
buybacks. We're comparing that's where
we are and it's actually very difficult
to think of ways in which we can measure
them. But in effect that's what we're
doing qualitatively in evaluation right
we're looking at that number and saying
what will happen to it over time and
maybe it's a good thing that it's
qualitative because if we're
quantitative then chat GPT could
probably measure the mode do the
valuation but you can think of your
exercise in valuation is trying to
measure the mode over time and what'll
happen over time so when I ask you what
will the return on capital be after year
10 what am I asking you will your
competitive advantages around now stay
on after year 10 it affects your value
and through it it'll show up. So it is
you know we use accounting returns but
do it with open eyes which is it's a
it's a flawed measure of returns but
we're going to go with it anyway which
brings us to the fourth way you can
create value. You can reduce your cost
of capital. You remember in corporate
finance class we went through optimizing
you can change the financing mix. That's
one. But you also in corporate finance,
if you remember, talked about matching
debt up to your assets. And if you
mismatch debt to assets, you increase
your default risk. So you can do that.
But there are two other things you could
try that we also talked about in
corporate finance, not in the context of
financing mix, but when we talked about
betas, remember we said if your product
or service is
discretionary, you'll have a higher
beta and if your product or service is
required that you'll have a lower beta.
If you can make your product or service
less discretionary to your
customers, you in effect lower your cost
of
capital. I'm not saying it's easy to do,
but every company that's basically what
they try to convince you to do, right?
You cannot live without a product. And
they try I mean, can you live without
Amazon? I don't think so. I I can't.
Maybe it's completely in my head, but I
don't I can't even visualize how I would
get toilet paper without Amazon Prime
anymore. That's how dependent I've
become on Amazon. And you got to give
Amazon credit. They've got me locked
in. You can make your product or service
less discretion. The other thing we
talked about was fixed cost. Remember
the discussion there was high fixed cost
push up your beta. If you can make your
cost structure more
flexible, you've effectively lowered
your beta, lowered your cost of capital.
So what I'm trying to say is when we
think about cost of capital, we think
about the debt mix. But that's only one
of four things you can think about.
Think more broadly. Make your cost
structure more flexible, your products
and
services less discretionary, match up
your debt, and you might be able to
lower your cost of capital without
changing your debt ratio at all because
that might be something you're entailed
to or the ratings agencies allow won't
allow you to
do. So, at the risk of repeating
something you've seen in corporate
finance, let's think about the mechanics
through which the debt mix plays into
your cost of capital. Let's go back.
Cost of capital is cost of equity times
the weight of equity. Cost of debt times
the weight of debt. Right? So what am I
doing here? I'm changing the mix of debt
and equity. Let's start with the easy
half. When I change my mix of debt and
equity, what will happen to my cost of
equity? It'll change. And what? So if I
increase my debt to equity ratio, what's
the mechanism through which I showed my
cost of equity? I have risk rate. I have
equity risk premium. Neither of those is
affected. But my beta is a lever beta.
So as my debt ratio changes my beta will
change my cost of equity will change.
Cost of debt is trickier right for most
of you use the current rating for the
company there. If I change the increase
the debt ratio it's clear there is more
default risk but the ratings agency is
not going to telegraph and say this is
what your rating would be. So here
you're stuck with that synthetic ratings
process of estimating what the interest
coverage ratio will look like if you
have more debt. It's always going to go
down and the interest coverage ratio
goes down. What will the rating be? The
one thing you cannot do, which I
sometimes see bankers doing that drives
me crazy, is just change the weights and
leave the cost of equity and debt as
they were before you change the weights.
Because if you do
that, adding more debt will always lower
your cost of
lo. I guess this is how you end up with
LBOs. Maybe some misguided banker just
leaves the cost of equity and debt at
what it is and keeps changing the look
at 99% debt. My cost of capital is
minimized. I just Why do you stop at 99?
I just score to 100% make it all
debt. Costs of capital are more dynamic
than that. They have to reflect those
changes. So the basic trade-off is when
you use debt, you're replacing more
expensive financing with less expensive
financing. That's always true. Equities,
but you're also pushing up the risk of
both your debt and equity. That's the
trade-off is that pushup know. So in
some cases adding debt will lower your
cost of capital. In some cases, it will
not. So if I were to present a picture
of changing the value of a company, it's
got to flow through all of those inputs.
Either I increase the cash flows from
existing assets, the value from growth,
reduce the cost of capital, or push out
the growth period through my competitive
advantages. So ready, you guys are all
going to be turnaround CEOs. You've
acquired a reputation as turnaround
CEOs. I come to you with a troubled
company. Is the way you're going to
attack creating value of the trouble
company going to be the same for every
trouble
company? Let's try it out. Let's suppose
my company is an oldtime manufacturing
company in a low growth business.
Where's your biggest potential for value
creation going to be at that company?
Michael, the assets versus cost cutting
because you have a lot of eggs and maybe
a factory and maybe the debt mix, right?
That's where LBOS's get targeted.
Oldtime mature and declining companies,
that's where you go. But if my company
is Intel, much trickier challenge,
right? Cost cutting is not going to get
Intel out of this
mess. Changing the debt ratio is not
going to alter their cost to capital.
This is a very different task you face
where you say, look, what is my pathway
out? And it's got to be some var some
pathway through growth where you decide
either Intel there's a niche market
where Intel is still a dominant chip
maker. It might be much smaller. You've
got to give up on the fact that you were
the greatest chip company in the world
15 years ago, 10 years ago, 20 years
ago. That's not coming back. But you can
see that cookbook
restructuring is never going to work.
And unfortunately, so much of the
restructuring I see, it's almost like
they're reading out of the same page of
the cookbook. Turn around CEOs get their
reputation by doing one thing at one
company and it worked, but there's
they're one trick ponies. You take the
next company, they try the same thing
over and over
again. Doing a true restructuring means
you understand. It basically means you
got to understand the business enough
that you know what levers to use. So
I'll give you a couple of companies.
This is SAP, German software company,
pretty well-run company, so you don't
have a whole lot to do. I've done a
status score valuation. What does that
mean? The existing management run the
company. There a couple of things that
should jump out at you. First is this
company's almost entirely equity funded.
Why? Because they're German. They don't
like to borrow money. Very conservative.
France. I'm sorry to pick on Germans,
but you
know, they're also a company that
reinvests, but primarily in Europe at
that time, primarily in Europe and the
US. They did not like emerging markets
and the chaos of emerging
markets. They're pretty well-run
company. The return on capital is 19.9%,
the cost of capital is 8.68%. They do
what they do well. So already when you
come to the company you can see that the
change you should make should be
incremental not dramatic because this is
not a dying patient this is a patient
with a maybe a slight fever and doing
surgery to cure light fever might not be
the right solution so here's what I did
first for SAP I said look that debt
ratio looks low but before I decide a
higher debt ratio is going to work what
do I have to check what the cost to
capital will look like at different debt
ratios and if you look at the mix cost
of capital decreases at least up to 30%
and then it turns a they have right now
2% debt they could be at 30% and we can
talk about where between two and 30 you
want but clearly it's in you can't
contest the fact that this company has
debt capacity that it's not
using so here's my restructured
valuation you can see I'm just going to
nudge the numbers on my reinvestments I
did push the reinvestment rate up and
the reinvestment is going to be in
emerging markets were growing saying you
didn't find a bigger footprint. I you
know that pushes up the growth rate. So
the effect on growth is relatively small
because it's coming from this marginal
additional reinvestment. I should have
been quite honest it changed the risk
premium as well. Do you see why? Because
the growth is coming from Asia. I should
have pushed out. I kind of missed that.
So maybe the cost of capital effect but
I did change the debt ratio to 30%.
Lower cost of capital slightly higher
growth. The value I get is €126 per
share. I know it status core value is
106. Oh, the banking 20% would have
worked pretty well here was completely
by chance. This is
Blockbuster. This was in 2002 2003
something last. It's a company that had
gone insane. Insane in what sense? They
kept opening 10 new stores and their
existing stores had nobody coming into
them. Okay. Their reinvestment rate was
26%. Their return on capital is 4%.
Already you can see the heart of the
problem. the return capital is well
below their cost of
capital. This is not a company where
you're going to tweak the reinvestment.
There's got to be a major surgery here
because there's something clearly wrong
with how you're trying to grow. Cost the
capital reflects the fact that there a
lot of debt 50% debt 50% equity. Okay,
here when I changed
it, I just did one simple fix. I said
just take zero net present value
projects. Is that asking for too much?
Remember that's easy to accomplish.
because you can't find projects that do
it. Just don't take projects at all.
Right? So that option is always on the
table. With that change built in, I get
a value per share of
$1247. Just stop investing. That's
basically it. Value of the share goes
from 513 to 1250. Sometimes doing
nothing, I think doing nothing gets a
bad reputation, right? Sometimes doing
nothing is better than doing something
that's destructive. In this case, doing
nothing increases the value per share by
150%. Carl Ian targeted Blockbuster
around this time. So there's a whole
host of reasons he might have done that,
but this is one of the reasons. Clearly,
it's a company badly managed and badly
run. So I would like you to prefer
your your the worst company that you can
think of and then take a look at the
company. If I became CEO of that
company, what would I do
differently? Try it with Weight
Watchers,
right? Try it with Bed Bath. I mean, Bed
Bath and Beyond is Weight Watchers. What
would I do
differently? It's it's a great exercise
in thinking creatively about fixing.
It's not going to be easy. I mean, let's
face it, no matter how well thought
through your plan is, it's not like
you're going to do it overnight, but you
have to have a plan that's tailored to
the company and its specific problems in
terms of fixing what you see as the
problem. On um Monday when I start, I'm
going to take your that's why I need
your numbers by Sunday because I know
Monday I'll show you what you know
you're most underleveled, you're most
overlevered. I will try to set aside
some time on Friday and I'll make it
zoom sessions for people have specific
questions on the project. This is not
about the finals. It'll be only about
the project. So if you're stuck on a
regression and you want to pass it by,
you know, you can drop by check it out.
So it' be time really not to if you're
saying how do I do intrinsic valuation
that's not the time to ask it, right?
That's too deep. But you're stuck on
what should I include in nonoperating
assets. That's a good time to come in
and show me what you're looking at. So,
I'll set some time apart so you can drop
in and we can we can get that done. But
I will see you on
Monday.
Yeah. Um